[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: I'm
Joanna, and I'm
here in the industry solutions
neighborhood of our expo floor
looking at this great energy.
All these people
are really excited.
And I'm standing
with Alok, who's
going to show us the NCAA demo.
You want to take it away?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
So this is our second
year at Google Cloud
being the official cloud
provider of the NCAA.
Our theme is Know
What Your Data Knows.
So we've been working
with the actual NCAA
data, basketball data--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, how fun.
ALOK PATTANI: --to make a lot
of insights and predictions.
So let's look at one.
We just had a national title
game, Virginia and Texas Tech,
and what we're
looking at here is
the number of possessions each
team will have in regulation.
So we predicted that the
number will be 63 or fewer,
and it was 59 in regulation.
So it was right.
JOANNA SMITH: Not bad.
ALOK PATTANI: But we've
done a bunch more.
So one of the other
things we did--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, nice.
ALOK PATTANI: --was we looked
at Data Studio dashboard.
So Data Studio, another
tool made by Google,
allows you to
visualize your data.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
ALOK PATTANI: We have developed
a bunch of different metrics
for all these teams in NCAA.
You can see them on the bottom
here, ScoreControl, Clutchness,
Discipline, et cetera.
But we wanted to surface
that data in a way
that people could
use, filter, and sort.
So this has all the 353 teams.
But if we just want to
look at the champion,
we can go here and
select Champion only--
JOANNA SMITH: Should
have been Tech.
ALOK PATTANI: --and,
boom, Virginia,
and now we can see
where they rank in all
the different categories.
JOANNA SMITH: No, I like it.
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Is that a
good score for Clutchness?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
So the ranks are right there.
So you can tell, it's
seventh out of 353 teams.
JOANNA SMITH: Not bad.
ALOK PATTANI:
That's pretty good.
They're third in ScoreControl.
They're a deserving champion.
JOANNA SMITH: So
you said this is
Data Studio, which we
know is for visualization,
which is really cool.
But you mentioned
other Cloud tools.
I think BigQuery played
a big part in this.
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Can you
show me how that works?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah.
So the first thing we have
to do is make a pipeline
to ingest the data.
So this is a small screen here.
But I'll show you, this is
on our Google Cloud blog.
We describe the entire pipeline
of how we built this data.
And you can see, there's
a bunch of stuff,
and then we get to BigQuery
right in the middle.
And I'm a data scientist.
I want stuff in BigQuery,
because then I can go and do
all my stuff, right?
So BigQuery, let's do it.
And then what we do from
there is we take the data,
we do a lot of
manipulations, and to build
that metric, like
ScoreControl, we
have to write a bunch of code.
JOANNA SMITH: All right,
so we got the cloud blog.
And then you also posted on
Medium, right, some more fun
insights?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah, so on
Medium what we did was we
wanted to talk more in depth
about how we built this metric.
So, one, we wanted
to describe in detail
for the technical people, but
also talk about the basketball
context.
So you have this thing, How
the Final Score Can Lie,
Score Control, right?
And in here, we go through
a couple example games
where teams control
the score differently.
But then, again, we
get back to BigQuery.
JOANNA SMITH: I love it!
ALOK PATTANI: And so
here is a long query.
And again, it looks
fairly complicated.
And it kind of is,
but it actually
is, when you think
about how you go
about doing this
calculation, BigQuery
makes it pretty easy with
these aggregation functions,
and it runs really fast.
JOANNA SMITH: And it may be
long, but it's easy to read.
ALOK PATTANI: And
it runs really fast.
Gets us our results for
all thousands of games
in a matter of seconds.
And then we can move
forward and do other stuff.
JOANNA SMITH: I
love scale power.
Now, you had one more
thing in this blog,
right, at the bottom?
I was playing with your,
what was it, an interactive--
ALOK PATTANI: Yes.
JOANNA SMITH: --scatter plot?
ALOK PATTANI: So if we keep
going here, eventually we
get to a point where we
see this scatter plot,
which plots all 353 teams
in their school colors
and shows their--
JOANNA SMITH: School colors!
ALOK PATTANI: --difference
between the ScoreControl
and a different metric.
JOANNA SMITH: I like it.
So if anyone wants
to kind of find it
at home, they can search
NCAA on our cloud blog,
or they can look [INAUDIBLE]
this is a cloud publication?
ALOK PATTANI: Yeah,
g.co/marchmadness.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh nice!
ALOK PATTANI: I know it's
a little bit past March,
but the tournament is--
JOANNA SMITH: No.
ALOK PATTANI: --still
fresh in our minds.
JOANNA SMITH: It
goes on forever.
ALOK PATTANI: So it
should be fun to look at.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, thank you
so much for talking to me.
OK, so now we're still
in the NCAA zone,
but we're talking to Abhi,
who's one of our students,
who got to do a really
cool integration
for this whole project
that I think is really
fun to talk about, right?
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: All
right, take it away.
Tell me about the overview
of what you built.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Sure.
So basically, the way our
campaign ended up starting
was we split into two teams.
The first was
competitiveness, which
looks at how close are games?
How many lead changes are there?
Basically, how exciting is
a game towards the end of--
JOANNA SMITH: Nice.
ALOK PATTANI: --the time?
And the second team
was explosiveness,
and this is all about runs.
So for example, maybe in
the last time into a game,
a team went on a 15 to 5 run.
What that means is
that the team scored
15 points and the opponent
only scored 5 points.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, OK.
Nice ending.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Yeah, so
the more explosive a team
is, the more likely they are
to go on these really big runs.
And the less time they
take to go on these runs,
again, that increases
their explosiveness.
So that was the
team that I was on.
And I got to do some
really cool data analysis
and exploration of the data
set that we were given.
Basically, the way that it
started was through BigQuery.
Now, one thing
you should know is
that I had never actually used
BigQuery before in my life.
JOANNA SMITH: They don't
just teach BigQuery
to all the students these days?
ABHISHEK SHARMA: I guess not.
I'm missing out.
JOANNA SMITH: All right,
so you got started.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Was it
intimidating at all?
ABHISHEK SHARMA: A little bit.
It was nice because
it runs using
SQL, which is a language that
I had learned in the past,
and it's a language that
almost every developer knows.
So when I actually got
into the BigQuery portal,
I realized, wow,
this is really easy.
There's an interface where
I can paste in my query.
I just need to put in the data
set that I'm querying from--
JOANNA SMITH: Music to my ears!
ABHISHEK SHARMA: --and
you get the preview.
JOANNA SMITH: That's awesome.
ALOK PATTANI: You can get a
preview right in BigQuery,
actually.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, nice.
ABHISHEK SHARMA:
So it's perfect.
Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So
it's all UI-based.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: That's
good for testing.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: And
another great thing
was that I could copy
this query word for word
and use it in Google Colab,
which is where I was entering
my actual analysis in Python.
And using Google Cloud's
BigQuery API, all I had to do
was paste in the
query, say what I
wanted the output
data set to be named,
and it would show in
my Python notebook.
JOANNA SMITH: So how
long do you think you
worked on this project overall?
When did you start?
And when was it kind of over?
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Yeah, I would
say, we began late January.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: So I
spent about 10 hours a week
on average.
Some weeks it would
be as low as eight.
Some weeks it would go
up to 12 to 15 hours.
And most of my time
was actually spent
on preparing data sets that
I could use for my analysis,
because it's really
important to have clean data
that you can
analyze very easily.
So I just spent a lot
of time using BigQuery.
It was just so easy.
Every time I ran a query,
just in a few seconds,
I could get my
results, and I could
import them to Google Colab and
do whatever I wanted with them.
JOANNA SMITH: That's awesome.
So thanks for talking to us.
ABHISHEK SHARMA: Appreciate it.
JOANNA SMITH: And
I hope everyone out
there feels like they're
just as capable and competent
as our young friend here.
ABHISHEK SHARMA:
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]